ben moi j'aime ce que j'avais à dire oui
un petit let's play qui arrivera dans
deux semaines première épisode qui
sortira le 5 décembre le 5 décembre
chien nous sommes le 5 décembre et tu es
très intelligent tu te doutes donc ce
qui va se passer
nous voilà tu laisses la fiesta vos
potes ça faisait longtemps
je suis hyper [ __ ] de content ça fait
super dont j'attends de jouer à jouer et
pourtant je n'avais pas joué au premier
c'est the last guardian voilà fait
parler mais qui avait fléchi à noves que
lotus un jeu qui a fait un buzz de
malades et pourtant je n'avais pas joué
une grosse merde cette fois-ci enfin
l'espèce sur un jeu très poétique très
s'en sort seul ans qui parle du périple
d'un petit garçon et d'une bête qui
s'appelle tricot t tricoter failli la
faire comme ça je fais plus c'est parti
il nomme autoroute ou non ils sont au
coude à coude avec toi ya main tutoie
écoles travaillent à passionner autant
savoir que notre mieux
voir
[Musique]
à l'after gamin
une usure
id the donnas et et amar tou a n'a t-il
à la brouille porto rico ils ont mieux
que t'es trop que ce soit en vo c'est
super cool
j'adore japonais
owings inc
pariez maintenant
deux côtes au cou
très bonne question
titus autonome mois il a accroché il a
accroché méfier même titre il faut que
je m'approche je vais pas me bouffe et
sereine avec suspense tout cas jusqu aux
toutous c'est tout les hommes qui sont
majeurs de bêtes au final ça il faut que
je le retire et femmes elle va me
démolir mais il faut que je le retiens
c'est pour son bien
allez allez on y va on y va en pratique
au ça va être rapide ça va être rapide
je suis désolé ces zones
ton super loterie quand je me réveille
il aurait réussi à se libérer vous
pensez oui vas en est dans sa carrière
le tricot se le demande
18h compassée bon alors du coup est ce
qu'il va me laisser l'approché en fait
je libère à mon avis elle tient plus
debout le pauvre [ __ ] do you do autour
du cou les bidons la haute tête de la
nourriture non à la mort on va aller
voir hop ça c'est pas de la bouffe merde
si c'est de la bouffe je vais lui amener
julian mais je pense que c'est de la
bouffe saisir avec rond à la vie avait
lui même racheté tiens
art pour le moi de rester baby cool
[Musique]
c'est moi qui s par mois qu'elle doit
manger attention tous les coups au maroc
comme elle est méfiant parce qu'elles
sont doux halieutiques
si on fait le point
là il ya un levier savoir quelque chose
ça à mon avis on rentre dans la cage on
trouve à un bidon bas le même que de
talent à revendre des classes et la
meilleure boucle chez pas et on va
lutter posé à ses pieds hamel à manger
ou pas là et puis là le bidon la manger
je pense à mon voiture dans le vide on
est là où il ya un bisou mais je peux
pas assis un petit trou ici je peux
accéder aux quais où je la mène voilà je
vais l'amener le dernier vidéo avance il
bouffe
tiens bon pas tout mais arrête terrible
ils mangent ou pas du coup il émarge à
chaque fois je crois
ah voilà ça fait du bien mon grand bah
oui
ils arrivent à se lever maintenant à
agatha do you this is our own aussi
outre les coûts n'ont qu'à nice to go to
qu'arago xxi sommes convaincus ce
dimanche au niger à son collier je pense
il ya un truc à détacher
tu étais donner à bouffer tu me tend la
main ou pas mais tu ne tolère pas faut
que j'aille le long de ton coller mon
grand laisse-moi laisse-moi panique pas
laisse moi j'espère vont se coller à
tadoussac
je vais le dégager ce monsieur je vais
dégager du coup allez courage courage tu
vas voir mal un coup c'est que ça va
aller
c'est bon ça va j'ai par ailleurs 18
heures encore
as roma qui doit faire des bonnes nuits
lui assez facile sans dormir avec tricot
à ibos les filles s'en veut et doit s'en
vouloir
même nous on a ce côté un peu quand nous
fait mal on a envie de frapper un truc
quoi ça donne c'est insoutenable
[Musique]
bah oui mon gars tu me tolère maintenant
ça va ap tricot si je bouge et que je
l'appelle il va venir si je vais là que
je l'appelle et bien oui
trop cool immense c'est ouf mon gars il
est totalement immense
je pense que le mieux en vrai c'est de
monter dessus en allant sur la chaîne ah
oui c'est bon vas-y j'ai rédigé un
jardin jeanne l'arrière lui il ya un
truc à tirer la voilà c'est ça ça va
libérer se marie enfin du jeu quoi wipro
a assez du bien ou quoi ok s'est
débarrassé maintenant il est
complètement libérée est en pleine forme
à mon grand tour assis trop court à la
bouffe tuer la bouffe je suppose qu'il
faut que j'aille là haut et que je passe
de l'autre côté on va se rejoindre c'est
ça mon grand tu as pas mal quand je
sortais plus comme ça
assez bon s'est passé bah voila j'ai
shooté dedans je suis attristé y en a là
aussi sur voilà ça c'est pour toi c'est
gratuit alors je vais passer de l'autre
côté on va se rejoindre je pense alors
où ça va nous mener
est-ce qu'on va pas tomber sur des
grandes étendues très très belle bien
bien ensoleillé non c'est la grotte
sombre et humide à y avait une chance
sur deux jeunots il va me rejoindre et
s'il est vraiment gentille ou si je vais
devoir faire d'autres trucs en plus
avant qu'il soit vraiment bien gentil
bien docile je pense qu'il sera jamais
vraiment dos il en fait c'est que sa
bombe avant ce qu'est ce qu'on a ici
derrick on peut utiliser sa saisira
ouais ça se retira c'est une lumière
[Musique]
parce que miroir et sa mystérieuse lui a
effectivement et l'autre sur tu peux
dire tu l'a volé mon gars je pense qu'il
ya un truc qui a illuminé après l'ex et
l'eau c'est faux c'est faux voilà mais
il se trouve que je revienne au jt au
début en fait je dis simplement tu
dormais tu faisais un petit somme
tranquillement alors montois tricot ou
je dois mettre ça à ça pas faire flipper
ça trouve il va
ah non vous dirais que ça change un
tricot suffit ça non what the fuck sais
pas c'est quoi la bombe atomique au
moins aussi attendu widow mouiller où
tous les coups n'ont pas très bonne
question
peut-être mais je crois que c'est ça en
tricot on fait quoi du coup on bouge on
ce qu'on fait on il faut lui remonter
dessus
vas-y guide mois guînois tricot c'est
pas faut aller là dans le jeu il nous
ramène d'autres
côté batterie à faire avec le miroir là
bas là il va falloir que je montre
peut-être une direction avec le miroir
et ça va le
l'attirer à en face là bas ça a l'air
solide way à toulouse i owe easy to cook
you to it with its tous ou la toux
attendu à new york
ouais bah c'est au vas-y fais fais nous
rêver ça merci nico et ballons gérant
son avance au gamin il veut pas avancer
c'est lui qui fait 28 mai de louer c'est
moi qui doit entrer en premier c'est ça
ok j'y vais j'y vais j'y vais j'ai j'ai
compris j'y vais il me suit en fait ça
bouffe attention tu marches tricorps tu
peux me croire
[Musique]
oui
well as pas l'air très mangeuse d'hommes
comme cette bête si elle avait été je
pense qu'elle mourrait bouffer quand
elle est au plus mal
voilà vraiment très gentils elle a un
capital sympathie assez ouf
tu t'en sors tricot ça pour toi c'est un
peu dur ça va aller mon grand ami je
suis très fin avec les animaux j'avoue
je suis très gaillard j'ai mes deux
chats g john bost et loi et c'est pour
ça que je voulais vraiment faire de
notre guidance et que je me doutais que
la relation entre le petit et la bête
elle allait être très très touchante
elle est très bien m'atteindre alors on
saute dans l'eau c'est partie d'entre
eux bien qu'au boulevard ensemble c'est
incroyable [ __ ] j'ai cru qui avait pas
de profondeur
tu sautes ou pas il veut pas se mouiller
allait bien regarde moi je suis bien là
tu viens c'est sa faiblesse c'est long
c'est ça sa faiblesse je pense elle
avait fait une grosse boom qui vivent
carrément lot de la salle bon je vais
aller là bas il ya des marges ça
m'intéresse à maintenant là bas il ya
une espèce de palissades que j'ai devoir
casser avec avec tricot donc premier
league
comment faire entrer tricot sens qui
touchent l'eau puisque apparemment il
n'aime pas du tout l'eau là je l'amenais
je vais l'appeler si bien là fait le
tour fait tour soit pas con à ce rythme
on voit qu'il a envie de me suivre qui
même déjà mais qu'il a vraiment trop
peur de l'eau est ce que ça marche à
distance sont son rayon
ah ouais d'accord
aw est d'accord il envoie vraiment là où
se pointe le miroir où va mon grand je
vais aller de l'autre côté tu va me
suivre
tu aimes c'est chiant soufflant dessus
aussi alors on va passer et on va
l'appeler non non bon alors il ya ça
fonctionne bien ça je suppose ouais
c'est ça là il ya un nouvel objet faut
que je prenne ça c'est c'est un objet et
que je peux pas d'accord on part sur un
biceps négatif de la part de cet enfant
alors la balle et il faut plutôt que je
le pousse ouais voilà ya assez de la
bouffe et donc ça va la tirer au balcon
vaincre sa peur par la boue il ya de la
bouffe en bas à lille
c'est drôle c'est un sens car un chat ou
un chien quoi aller ramasser plus on se
casse il nous amène il a intrigué par un
endroit à il va permettre d'attendre
cette montée c'est ça merci criques aux
eaux qui vient de sauter nous a menés là
on est au top la jarre a besoin de toi
pour atteindre le truc est là où par
contre ramène toi je suis désolé retirer
les plus mon gars fois du jeu tu auras
plus aucune plume a donc il faut que
j'escalade via ce report là ok j'ai
compris
eh ben c'est x et bats c'est fois et
merci tricot peut être par là du coup
ouais c'est ça ok je devais scanner par
mois ok mais nous brise le coeur cet
enfant là mais non avec souley je me
suis attaché à cette petite bête enfin
petit tranquille
[Musique]
ah oui bah
c'est très drôle
allez musique mon gars allez musique
cuisine et à la 12e' à la caste accord
innocad à toulouse il ya un an montre
qu'à tous les coups c'est tout
ko mitre au cous et de tous nos autres
se les sont petits cris il est content
d'avoir retrouvé liberté je pense qu'il
faut longer le mur cas là c'est ça doit
être le chemin à mon avis ouais ouais
c'est ça ouah c'est tendu le psy marche
de manière tendue imta encore plus avec
sa démarche quoi arrête à je pense qu'il
va falloir cd de la chaîne bientôt ouais
il ya un trou je devais nous tous
aujourd'hui j'ai rejoué d'un génie alors
que nantes juge que c'est assez
instinctif et monsieur lots de bois sur
ses biens fais attention à toi c'est pas
très stable il à l'agilité du charbon on
a atteint l'autre côté tricot nous a su
jusqu'au bout j'espère il est où
ok il continue c'est pas très stable tu
es bien sûr un jeu tout va on va au
tricot ici on va avoir besoin de toi
choix là je vais te monte dessus et tu
va m'aider alors on y va mon gars tu
sais ce que tu as à faire tu le sais je
n'ai pas besoin de te le dire amener à
tempêter la porte la halle et plates moi
ça
merci on sait fois hélas
un sérum annoncé un coût mais a beau
succès bon ok on va y aller à temps que
je passe ticos 3,6 alpes est j'aimerais
pas tomber dans le vide avec toi j'aime
pas question d'enlever nos petits mais
bon il est très serein
beaucoup de respect envers son animal on
continue on arrive dans une nouvelle
place un choix qu'il faut aller toujours
tout droit à non la grille a l'air fermé
est-ce qu'on peut l'ouvrir d'ici non non
et bien faire mais il est coincé
non il peut mettre que sa tête à temps
j'arrive tu écris on va monter en mars
et pas moyen de déjà de choper tricot
octobre ce qui doit être beau rebond le
cas car c'est bien là on va l'appeler
alors il vient s qui va sauter vous avez
bien a été fidèle way pièce mon pote tu
as je pensais même pas qu'ils allaient
pouvoir rogner montgrand aller trouvons
la sortie si tu me fait monter là dessus
moi je peux sauter m'accrocher là et
accéder à ce morceau là de balcons 1
yes merci mon gars alors où ça va nous
mener non nulle part on la loose amex et
ça en fait je vais devoir te re tout et
tu le prends pas mal
ok merci voilà il va falloir que
j'escalade ces trucs là ouais voilà
comme ça ouais non c'est mon gars comme
ça j'ai hâte un sayan chaîne là-bas ok
on y va hop
ok tu es un monde super bowl ha ok on
atterri là ok on va là nouveau chemin en
hauteur tricot il peut pas nous suivre
on est très tristes mais je pense qu'on
va le retrouver juste après à de la
bouffe
ah bah je vais l'attirer en fait je
pense qu'il ya certains endroits à mon
avis la mécanique c'est qu'à certains
endroits auxquels il a accès que quand
tu mets de la boue comme l'eau tout à
l'heure c'est non il veut pas y aller il
y aura non pas de bouffe je suis pas là
bas mon grand mais depuis quand tu me
suis comme ça bon bah tiens met toi bien
à la voile a tout à fait les frères on a
cru que tu as déjà perdu l'appétit
hop hop on y va
baixas et rico il pas pour passez la
porte et il ya une autre porte que cette
fouille peut pas casser merde comment je
fais allah ya un trou ok donc ça c'est
clairement les mécaniques de gameplay de
jeu en gros l'enfant n'a accès à
certains endroits où tu qu'on n'a pas
accès le but c'est oit cpo c'est pour
comme c'est beau il a escaladé tu parais
combien tu es incroyable dit quoi c'est
bon ça va bien tu es incroyable mon
grand tu me tues mme collin tu me lâches
plus on est meilleurs potes maintenant
toi et moi beau immensément des
environnements immenses quoi comme
shadow of colossus à ariel hayatou est
tous là où il ya la tour je pense qu'il
faudra gagner en hauteur un moment donné
mais je sais pas trop quand tu t'en
penses tu ricco sella correctement pas
et tu m'attends pas c'est comme ça toi
et ils sont bas les couilles mais
attends voie métrique or je suppose que
j'aurais dû être sur ton dos quand tu as
fait ça
allez revient à relire voir faire ça ok
désolé mais quand je devais faire un
aller-retour pour rien mais tu vois pas
prévenu ou tu me prévienne montpetit
tricot aux non non je veux vraiment pas
être tout le monde quand tu vas faire ça
je vais lâcher prise c'est sur dix morts
autour des travaux je suis posait entre
le mur et est plus prosaïque
ok on est bon alors nous voilà donc de
l'autre côté du mur de la poussée quoi
ça vous c'est nouveau ça
euh c'est pas qu'il fallait que je fasse
au menu vidéo et je le caresse
il est trop adorable ce tricot allez
viens mon grand de grandes aventures
nous attend de toi et moi on gagner en
hauteur mais c'est le but je pense un le
but c'est d'atteindre cette fameuse tour
donc de gagner plus possible en hauteur
hockey en arrivant au il colle son fonds
à la pierre froide le pauvre ya au top
[ __ ] elle a le petit prend des risques
à séoul non ouais arrêter le lagon car
nice on lâche la prise et on y est
parfait dajka t'inquiète je vais toit de
levier j'ai trouvé le viet ont fait
passer juste là t'en fais pas parfait
viens par ici et mon ami tiens mon gars
en plein vol au chien c'est comme si
c'étaient les premiers pas de bébé à
l'eau continue à jouer a besoin de toi
mon grand allez tu me fais plaisir de
fêter ça
qu'elle a commencé à monter on est dans
la tour ouais on est bon là la peur de
quoi
tafer de quoi tricot pour achever un
caissier à tricot tranquille
de quoi tu as peur tricot je comprends
pas ce qui suit nous fait là c'est ce
truc là où celui qui lui fait peur mais
je sais pas ce que c'est je sûr que
c'est un truc qu'on va l'électricité ou
pas c'est un truc pour les capturer
oh non
tu vas faire
oh merde ça le met en mode violence et
ça ça le rend méchant c'est ça
oh ça leur homme méchant du camp fait
ces bêtes là qui tuent les hommes n'ont
à la base elles tuent pas les hommes
c'est les hommes qui les ont rendus
comme ça en utilisant ces instruments
jeu monde c'était prévu ou pas je me
fasse manger là je me réveille je suis
avec tricot qui vit maintenant il dort
et bah oui maroc hôtelier tout c'est
vrai ça mais comment je fais du foot tu
es bon j'espère que je n'aurai plus
besoin constamment [ __ ] ils allèrent
hs à et la saignée aussi un bon je peux
quand même lui monter dessus quand il
est mal bon je sais c'est pas cool de ma
part mais je voulais juste vérifier
peut-être que la de la houle et me
permettait d'accéder à un truc en fait à
regarde ça qu elle pas mais que ça se
trouve ya un truc à faire attends
attends si j'ai trouvé ça c'est
exceptionnel
[ __ ] je suis fier olala c'est là qu'il
faut aller
[ __ ] c'est bien pensé mais s'il ya un
passage dans le mur ou pas ouais du coup
je suis sous la passerelle
qu'est-ce qui a
quoi ça
encore lié tizi ouzou l'it à hugh laurie
hawn ozie boo ici ah bah ouais c'est
quoi ces armures à auzielle iron man là
on arrive au on arrive au bout du tunnel
j'avais envie de le dire en chantant
parce que là j'ai un peu la pression
elle si elle sait pas c'est bon on monte
c'était shell à un levier hockey up
bon faut que j'arrête rico éléments il
est hs bomba mais qui a pas le choix
faut que j'y aille sans lui et au pire
les armes et à communiquer ma mère elles
vont buter c'est sûr ça ne leur ai
jamais dit je préféré les éviter moi là
je les invite pas je vais devant a lâché
moi ok fujian ok je vais les attirer
vers clicquot sa tête le réveiller on va
tenter ça seras tu les gardes si commun
que j'ai besoin de toi de ouf j'ai
besoin de toi de ouf
ah ça le réveil au moins on a choisi la
bonne stratégie
ça fait moins les malins quand mon
meilleur ami est là elle est tombée très
court à tout cela parle voilà très très
bien bravo mon grand c'est bien autour
de nantes où tu as tout
k7 sykora plus que je caresse je me
caresse le car elle caresse d'accord
c'est juste la manière où je vois le cas
mais ça va bah mon grand tu nous as fait
une phase la jetée parce qu'elles font
si le maire bio mais elle jouit mal à
laissac ares sa caresse sa caresse a
fait du plaisir c'est bon il va mieux et
bien voilà les amis sa fin de ce premier
épisode sur the last guardian je sais
pas plus et gagnent n'hésitez pas et
même tout comme d'habitude plus que
jamais j'espère vraiment que ça ou bien
parce que c'est un engagement de faire
naître plus on sait jamais ça va trop
plaire et on s'engage à faire des vidéos
sur le jeu quand même je terminerais jeu
quoi qu'il arrive je veux pas le
commencer l'arrêter s'il appelait pas
donc j'espère que ça vous plaît mais moi
en tout cas ça me plaît et c'est
important puisque sinon [ __ ] c'est mal
barré
là je suis très sensible je suis très
sensible à ces jeux comme ça autour de
l'amitié se boucle en plus un animal et
j'adore les animaux je vous dis à très
bientôt pour le prochain épisode je
pense que je vais être en ligne des
épisodes tous les deux jours voilà même
ça tombe sur un jour où je mets en ligne
une vidéo habituellement lundi mardi
mercredi ou vendredi
eh ben c'est pas gravure à deux vidéos y
aura l'épisode du est plus plus la vidéo
normale après l'ajout balancer comme ça
se trouve je remettrai pas des fois que
notre jour j'en sais rien mais
j'essaierai d'en publier aussi souvent
que possible et je pense que au total le
solo fait 15 heures vu que je joue une
heure et demie par vidéo on en a pour
dix vidéos merci jean michel matte à dam
se bos est nommé savoir garder portez
vous bien tu as tout le monde puisse